[Music]
welcome to the iron lords podcast
hello everybody how you doing this is
pete also now though here to give you
another uh first look at a pretty pretty
old game but uh it's a goodie
um it's something that i just started
encountering now
and starting to play and uh every so
often i'll dabble in with my community
um it is called deep rock galactic now
the game is
first of all it's um
it's all over
on xbox playstation pc all that fun
stuff uh it is also um you know on game
pass um
hint but i wanted to talk about this
game now number one uh it is uh they do
seasons
they have lots of different patches on
it it's on season two right now
um
i'm just gonna give you a quick overview
of what it is and why it's fun
so you take the it's a first person
shooter
gathering type game you take the role of
a dwarf
uh which i was they're very funny um i
was a terrible dwarf uh voice and
sounding but you know i'll go with it
so you're ending up playing as a dwarf
and uh you're
told to go mine in this cavern and to
look for specific items so uh what you
end up doing is
you end up uh jumping in there you end
up going into the um
into the into the uh cave um and you end
up mining whatever supplies and whatever
you need and while that happens you get
attacked by different type of creatures
within the
in the space
uh the more people now this is a
four-player co-op game uh and uh what
ends up happening is the more and more
you play
the more and more you end up getting um
more the weapons start increasing your
armor starts increasing your weapon
powers start increasing you even get
different types of weapons to play
now
in the in the video you know it's just
going to be uh it's probably a quick one
and it's just going to be you know
basically showing you you know one of
the levels you're gonna end up playing
um there's different types of levels uh
there's ones where you have to hook up
all the steam pipes
uh and then you end up uh you know
extracting the the uh the minerals
or you have to go in there physically
mine them then throw them into your you
know into your casher and then you end
up taking the cashier ends up coming
back up now
uh the the reason why this game is so
much fun is because
you're playing with your friends um and
on top of that you have this uh drop-in
dropout type scenario where
if you're playing and you're playing by
yourself you can end up queuing for the
world
and uh people can then just join your
game i'm not 100 positive if it's a
cross-play game um please if anyone ends
up knowing that please put them in the
comments below
um but
it was a lot of fun and
you get to play as four different type
of classes you get there's a scout class
a drilling class
uh an assault class
and an engineer class
uh so your engineer gets to do some cool
stuff like put down specific turrets
um your uh your scout class can uh you
know shoot out a flare to like lighten
area so that you can end up um
doing that
uh so
your you know your assault guy you end
up doing you know
assault rifles and fighting and doing
things like that
so you have multiple different types of
classes to play and they all play
uh fairly differently except for you
know they all have the same objectives
um and they got some really really cool
features um
i think it's the engineer i can end up
shooting tow ropes so if you need to get
to a location that's hard you know use
your toe rope
um the ski like i said uh the
it's it's fun and uh
it's banks for players
and you know you're just playing you're
just busting your friends all the time
and have fun and it's a good game to
play just to just chill
and the seasons are pretty nice because
you know they have little objectives in
there that allow you to do a whole bunch
of different types of stuff
um
so it's all it's all good
uh
so it's a lot of fun and i really really
think that if you get you know if you
have time uh by all means uh go ahead
and uh pick that up and like i said it's
on game pass like what do you what do
you have to lose it's game pass
um anyway once again my name is uh peter
sneldo that is
s-n-a-l-y-g-o uh you can find me on
twitch uh five nights a week monday to
friday from 3 p.m to 11 p.m uh playing
some different games it's a lot of fun
uh you can also check the irons podcast
out on friday uh friday nights that is
not right it is sundays
uh and it's about midday uh and you
gotta go check those guys out they will
give you all types of gaming news and
then i have a lot of fun uh so
definitely definitely definitely go and
check them out uh and uh also uh you
know where's the gaming.net go go online
check that out uh laurenceygaming.net
it's where you know you can find all
your gaming news uh they publish
multiple articles per day and uh they're
a fantastic group of writers so go and
check them out all right thank you again
everybody have a fantastic rest of your
day bye everybody
move your butt come on man
oh
cheese
so how much
actual work do you have to have done
from home
what's that one let's do
that's pretty cool
um
fix this line
cheeks
fix these lines
[Music]
you